volver a casa en medio de un ambiente
enrarecido miles de personas dejaron
atrás Shanghai para celebrar el año
nuevo lunar en sus lugares de origen un
retorno que se da en medio de un
pronunciado aumento de contagios por
Kobe 19 y que podría haberse afectado
por los desplazamientos masivos por todo
el territorio chino
no estoy preocupado por el virus porque
nuestra inmunidad está bien porque somos
jóvenes no me he dado positivo desde la
reapertura china se enfrenta a una
oleada de contagios desde que el
gobierno eliminó de manera repentina una
muy estricta política de cero covid que
se mantuvo vigente desde el inicio de la
pandemia y que derivó a finales del año
pasado en un hartazgo ciudadano que se
tradujo en manifestaciones sin
precedentes contra el gobierno de
Aunque la eliminación de las
restricciones Ha generado preocupación
alrededor del mundo esta ha sido un
alivio para muchos estoy muy feliz
debido a la pandemia estuvimos
encerrados durante tres años lo que fue
particularmente largo finalmente se
levantaron los bloqueos ahora es mucho
más fácil volver a casa la Organización
Mundial de la Salud ha sido reiterativa
al demandarle al país cifras verídicas y
transparentes sobre el número de casos y
de muertes unos pedidos que según las
autoridades chinas han sido cumplidos a
cabalidad
en el breve periodo de poco más de un
mes el china ha realizado cinco
intercambios técnicos y un diálogo con
la Organización Mundial de la Salud las
contribuciones positivas que china ha
hecho a la lucha mundial contra la
pandemia de Kobe 19 han sido ampliamente
reconocidas por la OMS y la comunidad
internacional
el sábado se conoció que desde inicios
de diciembre 60.000 personas han muerto
por causas relacionadas al coi 19 en el
país asiático hasta la revelación de
esos datos china solo reconocía poco más
de 5000 muertes por la enfermedad